[Music]
we're inside this new Hyundai Santa Fe
and we're checking it out so thank you
Hyundai's you're sending us out here to
Utah we get to check this beautiful
beautiful city we're in Park City and we
get to check out this awesome su feet
this is so cool Isaac would you like to
do the honors he's been waiting the
weather's perfect open it alright so
we're gonna be heading off now we're
gonna be test driving this new Hyundai
Santa Fe and honestly we are actually in
the market for an SUV so this totally
coincided with our plans because you
know we've been talking about babies in
the future our cars are pretty old we
really need my height man
my visual height men a new set of wheels
so this is actually a perfect
opportunity to check this out we get an
extended test drive beautiful scenic
Utah and then you know it's also kind of
cool for me sucks for Casey I am the
only one that gets to drive
and there's not fair the one that's
always been like let's not flying your
let's go road trip and let's explore our
country and and you're like I don't like
road trips I'd only be stuck in a car
but you're the one so excited right now
why I am
well I mean the reason why I don't like
cars againi sucks in the car is because
I get carsick or I used to get carsick
growing up like in like family it was
never about enjoying the ride it was
always about get to the destination car
as fast as you can we hate being stuck
in traffic that's like this is kind of a
really cool different experience for me
since I'm not used to this because he
you grew up with road trips yeah I've
never done I grew up with family cars
that's reason why I've been wanting to
get an SUV that's the next car we got to
get all right let's roll all there's a
heads-up display that's cool oh I could
see my miles per hour in the window
really future wait what do I go you
might not make a left on Royal Street so
uh I'm always just a dad right I
wouldn't mind getting an SUV now that
I'm driving this look at this view Wow
man I can't get it over this view look
like a painting
[Music]
man I feel like we're in a car
commercial right now like this is where
they come in car commercials Oh kind of
technically we are since this video is
sponsored but you know what I mean like
I'm like living it right now
[Music]
I really am genuinely thinking of
getting this SUV cuz it drives so smooth
it looks really nice and it has all
these really cool high-tech features
that I'm not used to since my car is
like eight years old but I honestly
really like it what are you doing back
here Isaac exploring yeah
you know what's cool you could look the
chairs oh nice hey longer road trips
you could lay down I think the goal now
is to get ya one sedan and one SUV for
the next line of cars that we'll have
for a family mainly because of the SUV I
imagine the car seats gonna be here
you haven't been to work yeah it's
really just breathtaking what is exactly
like they do I have seen ever knew how
beautiful Utah it is like right now we
go all over the world women everywhere
on country know Utah actually makes me
feel like this is how life is supposed
to be how are supposed to see the world
s not like just New York with buildings
you're just supposed to see it as
Richmond out alright so speaking of SUVs
and having babies tip are you ready to
have a baby
oh really
because the year ago almost exactly a
year ago we made a vlog about how before
we action have a baby it was to travel
as much as possible and get that travel
bug out of your system and I think we
have honestly like I mean ever since
then though ever since I've said that
like a year ago I already have like this
entire Amazon wish list of baby stuff
only fully prepared unless to do is
press by all and we're set but yeah like
I fantasize about having another baby
all the time and then every time you
know we care here at kids fate I mean
our friends kids or you know my nephews
are just babies in our lives
I'm always picturing it being my kid
I've been having dreams of us having a
baby like me being pregnant or me
holding a newborn
and I'm just like oh my gosh the baby
fever like knife-like biologically my
body is like girl get yourself pregnant
right now but then yeah like I don't
know that's like my emotional side and
then my logical side it's like relax you
got time you're still young you don't
even 30 yet don't worry about it there's
still a lot of things you want to do
before getting pregnant because
obviously once once we do this baby
boomer we're going and we're diving deep
into baby world and what we're knocking
two in a row kind of thing yeah I want
to do it back to back because I don't
want to have another hotel situation my
poor baby Isaac I didn't mean to but I
made you an only child
you still eight I mean it's not too late
you're still gonna have your sibling
thing one way well that's the foot I
grew up as an only child that's why I'm
like bummed out that that happened so
then once we knock out the first one
another one another one like is there
anything else I want to do before having
another baby and I'm like I guess I can
in a perfect ideal world would make me
feel like yeah there's no doubt like we
should get pregnant now like I would
like to have like our own home that'd be
nice cuz we are renting right now even
though like I really love the place we
live in right now but it would just be
nice to own it you know having a little
bit more of a cushion in the bank
account out that'd be nice to just took
like not have to worry about that stuff
honestly the only two things like I feel
like our relationship we're good I think
would love to have a sibling already
your parent would love to be
grandparents already you would like to
be a dad already brand new baby I've
never experienced the parenting of zero
through four so very curious it's just
really cute to draw Chucky and stuff
thank you 10 a ten-year-old I'm so cool
look at me I'm cool kind of way he's
reverting back yeah he's he's I give you
0 to 4 good and I guess the other parts
of me that make me not want to it
because I remember all that hard work
like I remember being up all night and
like potty training and like it's just
it's so much it's full much work like
you really don't know how much work for
those 0 to 4 years do you think it takes
such a huge toll on you then I'd only
just after the kid for but even creating
the kids the pregnancy like that's a
whole nother situation like it was hard
but I know everyone around me there's a
lot more support I had I think I was 18
anywhere I went I just got nothing but
dirty looks I go how dare you be a young
mom and it was just really hard like it
was a hard time with my life especially
doing it mainly by myself like I didn't
really have a lot of support around me
it was just like I can't like I think
about having another baby and I can't
play the game of having a baby
very realistic yes to me you think you
have to fully know what you're getting
yourself into
I don't know I think with the X amount
of years I've had with Isaac now I feel
like I'm a lot more mature now than I
was even a year ago hitting 30 now I
don't I just feel like I'm I'm very
ready for all this we'll see what what
what's in store for us in the next
couple of months maybe maybe another
year I'm out nervous right now you said
months of my heart drops oh my god you
get nervous I do get really nervous
though thinking about having a baby just
because I think the more real the
decision becomes the more nervous I do
get about it I think it's like marriage
do you know you're nervous about that
too for some reason it is
you have like good known how true true
your fear is from experience and my fear
is from but I'm player 2 I'm player 2 if
we're doing co-op this time player 2 i
centered the game do you think you're
ready to pick on the Big Brother yeah
yeah what are you looking forward to
most about being a big brother when I
was like six like I want to play with
play video games but now by the time my
little brothers oh we're having a
brother or sister either if once they
have the mind to like play video game or
have fun when I play a board game I'll
be too old
wheeler wheeler basement you prefer a
brother or a sister sister rather I have
a sister than a brother
yeah okay I know how annoying it is so
you want to know how annoying it is yeah
we said it's gonna be annoying a lot of
people don't like their brothers or
sisters everyone that you love in your
life are gonna at one point or another
annoy you get on your nerves you're
gonna have to deal with everything that
comes with that so I know I daily basis
after putting this on
Street the Main Street is so cute it
looks so historic and everything it's
like one of those towns that you see in
there anyway we're about to eat
[Music]
we are going to Olympic Park so this is
where they had the Olympics at one point
in time and this is where Olympians come
and train for the Winter Olympics so we
get to zipline today so I'm excited
about that how do you feel baby I know
he's super excited I'm really excited
but there's something in me
I'm scared you know when you're always
scared to get butterflies or something
your adrenaline yeah gentlemen honestly
if the planning it's not that bad like
it's kind of like a swing you know like
we go back and forth back and forth but
instead of going back you're just going
forward the whole time that's it boy
[Music]
anyways yeah you're alright cuz it'll go
like real fast and then once he stopped
thank you now we're gonna go to be ready
for this Isaac huh nervous you're
nervous cute
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]